(music)
- This traditional water mill can grind
over 550 pounds of flour in a single day.
(music)
This is the Lurgashall Watermill
of Weald and Downland Museum
in Singleton, West Sussex.
- The way we make the flour
is exactly the same way
as it's been made for generations.
The wheat goes in at the top,
the flour comes out of the bottom.
We don't add anything in at all.
We don't take anything out.
(music)
- [Narrator] The Lurgashall
Mill dates the 17th century,
but despite being over 400 years old,
it hasn't always been
in the same location.
Its original site was
the Lurgashall village
in West Sussex, which it is named after.
The original mill had two
water wheels in tandem,
each wheel driving its own
independent set of machinery.
With time, only the tail
water wheel remained in use
and the cast-iron wheel
replaced the wooden one.
The Lurgashall Mill was incorporated
into the museum in 1973.
The museum carried out restoration works
of the machinery and the interior,
but it was still lacking
something essential.
- The problem was that on this
site we don't have a river.
So, we had to engineer
a whole water system,
dig out a big pond, and line it
because underneath is
chalk, which absorbs water.
And then, below the wheel
we need another pond
to collect the water.
That had to be dug out and lined.
And because there's no
river, we have to pump
that water back up and reuse it.
- [Narrator] Nowadays, the mill is used
for grinding corn, flour, and animal feed.
It supplies to small bakers and farm shops
around the Singleton village.
We followed a journey of a bag of wheat
as it is milled into flour.
The mill is structured over three floors.
The top floor, where grain is fed from,
the first floor, or stone floor,
where the grinding takes
place, and the ground floor,
or spout floor, where a horizontal shaft
connects the water wheel to the machinery.
- The mill's driven by water and so,
we need to have water
flowing over the waterwheel.
We start the mill
by taking a very large spanner
up to the sluice gates,
which control where the water comes out
of the big mill pond.
We open the sluice gate,
water then flows along a channel,
at the back of the mill, until
it reaches the water wheel;
and it starts to fill
up what we call buckets.
They don't look like the bucket,
that you would use for
cleaning your floors,
something like that; but,
each slot contains water,
and we need to fill about four of those,
before the weight of the
water makes the wheel turn,
and then the water tops up the next one,
and the next one so it
keeps turning continuously.
- The mill is 12 feet in
diameter, when grinding,
it turns at about six
revolutions per minute;
each complete turn is powered
by 200 gallons of water.
(music)
- When we need to mill, we
take a bag into the mill,
and we use a chain hoist,
to lift it up to the
top floor of the mill;
we then open the bag,
sometimes the string will pull,
sometimes we have to use scissors,
and we then poor it down the chute,
into a hopper above the machinery.
(music)
- In this big barrel,
there are two stones,
just like these miniature ones,
the bottom one called the
bedstone that doesn't move,
the top one called the runnerstone,
is turned by the machinery
and is the one that is
actually doing the grinding.
- We can control the grade of the flour
by the amount of grain that we put in,
and the distance apart of the stones,
and everything is checked,
by what is known as the rule of thumb.
With no gauges, no machinery,
we just use our thumb and our forefinger,
and if it feels right, it is right.
(music)
- Overall the stones
rotate 13 and a half times,
each rotation of the water wheel,
at an average speed of 80
revolutions per minute.
- I enjoy the fact that
when I come to the Museum,
at the end of the day, I
can look at a pile of flour
and say: "I helped to make that"
and because we're also a
museum, and we have visitors,
its fascinating to talk to the visitors,
and some of them tell me stories,
about how they have
seen a mill being used,
when they were children.
You get people who come from
various parts of the world,
telling us how it was used,
one lady from Cambodia,
told me how to make
rice noodles using one.
(music)